remember the time you fell off your bike
or bumped your head on a sharp corner
childhood injuries are things we'd often
like to forget but our bodies often
carry the memories in the form of scars
so what are these unwanted souvenirs and
why do we keep them for so long after
that unintended vacation to the
emergency room
the most common place we see scars are
on our skin a patch that looks slightly
different from the normal skin around it
often this is considered an unfortunate
disfigurement while other times
deliberate scarification has been used
in both traditional and modern cultures
to mark a rite of passage or simply for
aesthetic decoration but the difference
isn't only cosmetic when we look at
healthy skin tissue under a microscope
we see the cells that perform various
functions connected by an extracellular
matrix or ECM this is composed of
structural proteins like collagen
secreted by specialized fibroblast cells
well-arranged ECM allows for
transportation of nutrients cell to cell
communication and cell adhesion but when
a deep wound occurs this arrangement is
disrupted during the process of wound
healing collagen is redeposited at the
wound site but instead of the
basket-weave formation found in healthy
tissue the new ECM is aligned in a
single direction impeding inter cell
processes and reducing durability and
elasticity to make matters worse the
healed tissue contains a higher
proportion of ECM than before reducing
its overall function in the skin the
overabundance of collagen interferes
with its original functions like
producing sweat controlling body
temperature and even growing hair the
scar tissue is fragile sensitive to
changes in temperature and sensation and
should be kept in moist environments to
maximize healing this presence of
excessive fibrous connective tissue in
an organ
is known as fibrosis and if that term
sounds familiar it's because our skin is
not the only organ vulnerable to
scarring cystic fibrosis is a genetic
disorder that causes scarring of the
pancreas
while pulmonary fibrosis is a scarring
of the lungs resulting in shortness of
breath scarring of the heart and the
buildup of ECM following a heart attack
can inhibit its beating leading to
further heart problems what's common to
all these conditions is that although it
retains some of the original functions
the scar tissue formed after a wound is
inferior to the native tissue it
replaces however there is hope medical
researchers are now studying what causes
fibroblast cells to secrete excessive
amounts of collagen and how we can
recruit the body's other cells in
regenerating and repopulating the
damaged tissue by learning how to better
control wound healing and the formation
of scar tissue we can utilize the
multi-billion dollar budgets currently
used to address the aftermath of
wounding in a much more efficient manner
and help millions of people live better
and healthier lives
but until then at least some of our
scars can help us remember to avoid the
sorts of things that caused them
Oh